[Music]
thermoplastic fire helmets are
lightweight but that doesn't mean they
aren't tough because of their chemical
composition these plastic helmets remain
sturdy even when exposed to temperatures
of over 500 degrees Fahrenheit develop
in the 1970s the helmets have become
standard-issue at many fire stations
there are a few situations more
dangerous than entering a burning
building thermoplastic fire helmets
weigh substantially less than other
alternatives these helmets are one piece
of equipment that won't slow down the
rescue mission the production starts
with the special blend of thermo plastic
pellets a vacuum pulls the pellets into
a hopper the pellets then flow into an
injection molding machine it melts and
molds the pellets into the shape of a
fire helmet a robot retrieves the helmet
and transfers it to a cooling station
a worker then clips off plastic that
solidified as it flowed through a
channel and into the mold this unwanted
bit is called sprue she wipes off
fingerprints and inspects the condition
of the helmet show the next worker trims
the brim to remove excess plastic that
formed when the mold closed for this
process he uses a blade with a curved
edge next he applies reflective strips
that will allow the firefighter to be
seen in the dark he drills holes for
attaching either goggles or face shields
and the worker adds a last reflective
strip he screws a support plate for the
ID shield to the front of the helmet
show he uses plastic screws rather than
metal because metal is electrically
conductive and would put the firefighter
at risk in the event of Electrical
sparking during a fire
[Music]
another worker now applies labels to the
inside of the helmet show the labels
indicate that this model of fire helmet
is in compliance with the safety
requirements the worker inserts high
density foam padding in the helmet shell
the padded cap will cushion the wearer
from the force of an impact this web of
straps will serve as a suspension liner
and will also support the helmet on the
wearer's head
[Music]
another worker installs a ratchet system
for adjusting the fit of the liner to
the firefighters head positioned at the
nape of the neck the firefighter can
turn the knob to pull the suspension web
tighter attachments on the suspension
liner fit into sockets on the helmet to
lock it in place he fastens the chin
strap to the helmet by wrapping the ends
around molded struts on both sides of
the shell the chin strap has a
quick-release button in the event that
the firefighter has to remove the helmet
fast another worker now folds up
flame-resistant ear flaps the flaps are
equipped with hook and loop fastening
strips that fit to the helmet he sets
the ear flaps aside while he inserts
snaps for goggles into brackets on the
helmet
[Music]
he screws the snaps snuggly to the
helmet the worker then wraps the fire
and fog resistant goggles around the
helmet and snatched them to it
[Music]
he tucks the maintenance instructions
into the helmet followed by the folded
ear flaps this thermoplastic fire helmet
is now complete but there's still one
last bit of official business
the worker screws the large leather ID
shield to the support plate the shield
bears the name of the fire department
and assemble that denotes rank this fire
helmet is now ready for duty it will be
one of the first things the firefighter
reaches for when he or she gets an
emergency call
[Music]